When you do the hook, you call and you're like,
hey, I want to send you a couple of free leads.
I saw you're paying for ads, blah, blah, blah.
I've seen a couple of posts where some of you guys are like,
hey, I sent the client the first lead and it's been a week
and we haven't gotten a lead.
Quit pigeonholing yourself or painting yourself in a corner.
Do you know what I do?
I tell the business owner, I say, hey, look,
I want to get you a couple of leads, two, three, four leads,
and then let's talk.
And I want to make sure they're good leads.
So that might be in a couple of days.
That might take a couple of weeks.
I'm not really sure.
It just depends.
It kind of ebbs and flows.
If you just said that, if you sent them a lead the first day
and it took a week to send them the second lead,
they would be fine because they're like, oh, yeah,
he told me it might take a couple of weeks.
The problem is you guys, without meaning to
or maybe you are meaning to, you're like, hey,
I'm going to send you three leads.
I'm going to try and do it.
Let's talk on this day at this time.
And I understand if you guys have websites that are already
generating leads, you can do that.
But if you're running ads, guys, shit happens.
Competitors click on your ads.
Your ad accounts get suspended.
There's weird weather issues.
There's holidays.
There's recessions.
There's shit happening and wars and all
these different factors.
People get spooked and the Dow Jones goes down
and we don't know all the factors.
So quit painting yourself in a corner.
Let the business owner know, hey,
I'm going to get you two, three, four leads.
Then we're going to talk.
I'm hoping to talk in not too long,
but it might be a week or two.
It might be a couple of days.
I just want to send you a couple of good ones.
That sound fair?
Cool.
Then guess what?
In their heads, they're expecting it potentially
to take a couple of weeks.
And you might call them in three days
and have all the leads that they need to close the deal.